joining me now is n Gingrich former
speaker of the house and Fox News
contributor uh new uh Trump as Hitler
Trump as Stalin Trump as whatever
dictator comes to mind that really is
their campaign along with the abortion
fear-mongering which they did they
believe to some excess success in um in
the last uh election a few weeks ago
what do you anticipate happening here on
out well I think the only thing I
disagree with in your general
explanation is that this is about their
survival I think this is literally the
behavior of an entire system which
understands that it's on the verge of
being destroyed uh they're looking at
what happened in Italy they're looking
at what just happened this last week in
Argentina there is a worldwide movement
against left-wing radical socialist
values you look at hungry I mean again
and again average everyday people are
saying no we don't want this you look at
the numbers for Trump right now they get
bigger and bigger and bigger and I think
what you're seeing on the left is a
desperation that's literally a survival
function uh we've never seen this maybe
the south in the 18 1860 but other than
that we have never seen this level of
desperation in American politics and
it's going to get worse they have a
candidate who's hopeless I mean if you
watch Joe Biden you know he's not going
to win and they can't get rid of him uh
they have a situation where their
opponent is getting stronger and better
and more disciplined and I think that
leads to a a very explosive moment in
American
history but new don't you also see that
their drive this is blood lust they seem
to have with putting Trump in jail I
think they believe that's key to their
survival too it you know they they have
to they have to put him in jail before
this election because nothing else is
working the the Hitler routine isn't
working obviously people are just
laughing at
that wow and putting them in jail won't
work either but the problem they've got
is it's I don't know how it happened I'm
I'm writing a series for the American
spectator I have to confess I'm not
quite sure how we get to where we are
today because it's hard to understand
how the modern left somehow went through
this permutation this this uh almost
mutant Behavior where they're now so
radically isolated they're losing
African-Americans they're losing Latinos
in the most recent poll they're losing
Young Americans they're losing
asian-americans I mean all the groups
they thought they could count on are
thinking these guys are nuts
and they're not going to vote for them
and they know they're nuts because of
pain pain in terms of uh Fentanyl and
crime pain in terms of the price of
living pain in terms of the number of
immigrants crossing the border every
time they turn around they see an
incompetent president who's clearly
Beyond his his part his due date I mean
a reasonable Democratic party if it
still existed and it doesn't would in
fact insist that Joe Biden step down
there is no Democratic party that can do
that and he's not going to step down and
if he did they'd get Camala Harris
because in their party in their
particular Universe you cannot defeat a
black
woman well n uh I got to say I I've seen
desperation before in politics but what
they're saying about about Trump wanting
to execute people he's going to execute
his political opponents I mean I think
they've completely I mean I hate to say
someone's lost his or her mind on
another cable network but I I don't know
how else you describe that I mean that
that's where they are that's the
Democrat what happened to Hope and
change what happened to all the optimism
that the Democrats
offered look I I last week I was in a
meeting with a formerly moderate
Republican very sophisticated very nice
guy somebody I like personally and as we
talked about Trump he became so totally
demonically convinced that this is the
end of his world I mean the language I
couldn't argue with him because the
language was so emotional it it was like
dealing with a person who was literally
Beyond
self-control and and I think that's what
you're seeing that's 20 or 30% of the
country now is in a in a mood of
literally being out of touch with
reality totally convinced they're right
and and
terrified yeah they're not pleasant
people to be sitting around a
Thanksgiving table with so just hide all
the sharp implements because they're
very angry people um n it's great to see
you have a Happy Thanksgiving my friend
as always hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else